[Music]
in snapped news Snuggie submit about her
eyebrows crazy why I saw was hazy woman
killed her fiance after arguing about
their wedding guess what
she's like the ultimate bridezilla dude
I think about weddings and just like
that whole guest part that [ __ ] is so
crazy to think about like who you want
to invite another fight and it's kind of
sad yeah and like for me too am I
thinking like let's say like somebody
that I were friends right but we're not
like tight like I'm tight with all you
guys that's the hard part like knowing
where to draw the line like when does
this person cross over here when does
this person cross over here or sometimes
you have that one friend you're not that
really close with but recently did you a
giant favor yes [ __ ] should I put this
person here but this person here this
person also has to come here weird thing
to like even like help I think I'm kind
of like the odd man out because there's
some people like well don't you feel bad
when they don't invite you like if we're
just friends and we're not tight friends
absolutely not
yeah I could give a [ __ ] then as I guess
you also have a pressure to dress up
show up give a gift
I don't care [ __ ] less so recently
somebody had a wedding and they're like
oh you didn't get invited I'm like no
thank God yeah they're like oh [ __ ] all
my this little awkward I was like it's
not awkward at all I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah even if he did invite me I probably
wouldn't have showed up yeah if I get
invited I'm like I didn't even know you
saw me like that so cool I don't see you
like I'll get mad what I don't bite you
we got one of those where um we didn't
even know the people that well they were
like do you want to be part of the
bridal party yeah I got one of those
jokes one of the best men best men well
we had to do brews me
you guys were part of the bridal party I
was part of the group dudes being
handled friends I guess not I think for
then it was like keeping up with the
Joneses type of mentality look we are
celebrities on our wedding no no this is
like when like I don't even think I was
on GK yet oh yes we had just yet that
was pretty famous up it's the people I
know like are you sure like don't feel
I'm like you don't even know me life is
fabricated yo one of the dudes dropped
out and I think they wanted to have like
three and three rather than just going
like who's actually tight right so they
asked me and I'm like there's so many
people in this role I live in a lie I am
because that just tells me like so many
[ __ ] people are so worried about
judgement how they look to other people
like just criticism and like how they're
appearing like [ __ ] that must be a
[ __ ] jail in your brain yes dude just
last year I did a video on this girl's
mentioning it was like this guy invited
me to be one of his groomsmen number one
it wasn't even in California so I had
the flight to butt-fuck middle of
America to go to his [ __ ] wedding off
to get a [ __ ] suit to match it what
they were doing
I met this dude a couple of times drunk
Dan barely remember his but you didn't
go no I didn't oh I had a conversation
with them and you know this was like
doing a weird part of my life where I
was just being extremely like me Munt
yeah just a little too blood no tact you
know so he called me up and I just was
like brah weird friends how'd you get my
number dude yeah so is this wait who it
was this after you became famous on
YouTube yes so they're just you they
want people want to use you yeah and so
it was so weird and I was like are we
even friends it was good and the thing
that pissed me off was how he phrase
what he said after he goes it's he goes
it's an honor to be asked to be
somebody's [ __ ] like groomsmen and I
was like [ __ ] privilege I don't know
you dude are you talking about British
royal family or so yeah like it was the
weirdest bignum should piss me off in oh
it's an honor I guess we'll have to do
work you're close to them yeah really is
an honor if you think about it right cuz
it's like you're gonna beat all their
wedding photos you're like part of the
important table like all of their
friends and family know who you are and
now you're presented to their friends
and family that you're important enough
for them to like stand out amongst all
those I view them as sleazy sleazy even
though whole wedding work stuff yeah so
like for example so like you know like
that's to win just trying to figure it
out new ways to view a vagina right ya
know cuz you know some girls some girls
they view that they put their vagina on
a pedestal so it's like it's your it's
it's an honor if I let you enter my
vision or whatever right oh that's me
right yeah and there's another one
that's like if it is on that pedestal
then why are you passing out two [ __ ]
strange [ __ ] and so if your
grooms men like if your groomsmen places
it's supposed to be here and it's
reserved for [ __ ] like Usain Bolt
[ __ ] Obama or whatever while you're
letting homeless people into your sleazy
well no I think your [ __ ] it's too
easy with your job for those people yeah
their sleazy but the way that the
traditional way of doing it it's not
sleazy but when they offer it to someone
like okay in a traditional wedding right
is it like the closer you are the
physically the closer you are to the
person so it's like the best man is like
my best they usually honestly do it by
pairing in height yeah I don't think so
it looks good but the best men in the
better what does the other one
bridesmaid maid of honor need of Honor
there's almost two that they're the ones
that are next time everything else
doesn't matter it's by heitor what looks
better so it's a maid of honor best man
and then groomsman and then the graves
mates oh I see we all should so
complicated oh my god because for me if
I if I do do that would you would just
you do if I were to do that like I don't
want them to work I just don't want
people to work at my wedding
that's a bridesmaid does well that's
what I'm saying I don't want them to
work so what it'll be is like yeah
you'll be the groomsmen or whatever but
you just gotta show up and take pictures
other than that you know why though I
think for tradition I think it's because
you're surrounded by people who live
extremely [ __ ] busy lives yeah
versus like I like you know weddings
that my cousin's had and everybody like
it was a fun event
we don't do human [ __ ] because it's like
you don't mean like we don't do regular
people [ __ ] and look at it like as oh
that's fun let's get let's go let's all
do this event together that's the
difference part of it but I think
another bigger part of it is that we're
just not traditional people like you
know like people that are in traditions
regardless of how much time they have or
not like it's it it means a great deal
the only person that I would be upset if
he didn't make me his best man would be
my best friend garbage because we've
been through so much together yeah and
then I just be like who's this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you don't mean like this
brother brother well that's what I mean
though it should feel not like a burden
but it should feel special yeah yeah
that's what I mean like regardless of
your traditional or not like if it's a
big event for your friend you should
want to go like [ __ ] yeah let's do this
right but if you don't feel that way
then that tells me that you shouldn't
even be a part of this [ __ ] that's true
yeah okay so let me tell you guys this
story oh yeah we haven't gotten into the
articles oh damn I thought we were doing
our own story off the record I thought I
was on the record so this takes place in
Colorado yes bride and groom or yeah
they're engaged all the professors the
fianc Suri's yes I'm tripping that was
another article
yeah the parasites I got 300 times today
[ __ ] turn into mahalia [ __ ] he's
punch-drunk Brandon and Jacqueline 33
and 31 years old
you got the smallest fingers from big
eyes dude no but they're meaty though
are they so short cut him some slack you
did think we were talking about
parasites still so we'll give it to you
yeah you got some big guy's fingers it's
because he's doing this with this hand
Oh
yeah he's actually it is I thought they
were short this fool just got 11 times
yeah tell me tell me I'm so sorry I
didn't tell you this story always wonder
what size gloves he wears [ __ ] you Mike
okay so Brandon and Jacqueline they got
home from a bar where they were
celebrating their upcoming wedding like
the friends and stuff and so when they
got home they started arguing about
their guest list because Brandon wanted
to this is all according to Jacqueline
Bo
so Brandon wanted to invite a woman that
he allegedly once had an affair with so
that made her believe that the affair
was still going what they don't know so
it's not over gifts it's just an affair
it's alleged alleged affair that's way
more serious than gifts no guest list
gasps listen that's way more serious for
some reason I was thinking like they
were fighting over the registry they got
all these gifts and they were pissed
about it and they killed each other
that would be way more funnier most of
the stories about this the first one is
that she said that at one point Brandon
came out of the bathroom too and that
she just saw that there was a knife
sticking out of his chest
what and so she pulled it out threw it
on the kitchen table then just called
9-1-1 oh my god Mario she claimed that
Brandon had grabbed her by the throat
Hurst pushed her up against the wall and
then he pulled out a steak knife and
this was all happening in the kitchen
and that she pushed him and he fell on
top of the knife that's a very bad life
Wow it was just those two two accounts
so obviously like they think she's lying
she told me it's where they actually
keep the knives in his chest Oh
originally she was just putting it back
in after she was done are you the knife
holder exactly the chef's knife pull a
knife you know that knife block that's
like a person the [ __ ] kungfu
Hustler's she had dudes so she was
charged on second-degree murder
yeah she looks way crazier there yes so
what's cuter me I think I'm purposely
put the lining down here to make you
more like scary people yeah good job
police officer nice set of chins
eyebrows are crazy so long yeah her
eyebrows go mmm
serial killer got some necklace going on
too which is you probably paid five
thousand yeah whenever you post bail you
pay like ten percent or some [ __ ] of the
actual bail that's why they have the
bail bonds because they put up the bail
for you when you give them five thousand
or whatever what do they get out of it
percentage interest yeah so like they
get money if you don't show or whatever
and then now they collect the money from
you and if you don't you know if you
don't show up and and all that stuff
that's when the bounty hunter comes so
that's why Dog the Bounty Hunter had his
own like bail it's just like
[Music]